- Is it true though, that
you got into some trouble
with your choice of footwear
on the show for your character?
- Yeah, it wasn't necessarily my choice.
It was an amazing Tina
Fey and Robert joke.
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
In the pilot, my
character wears flip flops
with all of his suits.
There was, just a throw away line
where his daughter says,
why are you wearing
flip flops with a suit?
And I say that I have
podiatric claustrophobia,
I don't know if it's a thing
but the character will
not have that anymore
because you could hear me coming.
You could hear my flip-flops
coming a mile away
in every scene.
- I can't wear flip flops
because that reason.
I don't know how people wear flip flops
without all the noise.
Like I don't understand it.
- I don't like the feeling
between my first two toes!
- [Kelly] Me neither, me neither!
- I'm a highly sensitive person!
- Me, I don't like that on my toes either.
Literally, my stylists
shared these shoes to put on,
and I was like, nope I'm
not putting my toe in there!
- It should be socially acceptable
to wear those novelty shoes
that look like giant foam sneakers.
(laughter)
- Clown shoes.
- Have you ever made any of
your own wardrobe choices?
- No, you've never don't
want me doing that.
- Wait, you didn't pick any of those hats?
- No, I was like a mopey gothy teenager.
Like I wasn't, I was not,
I'm still, I'm not a fancy,
this is all just smoke and mirrors.
- You're not mopey!
- When I was a teenager,
I was, you don't know me!
- I know you, I was like,
whatever, you're dead.
- The cameras turn off sometimes.
- And then we become different people.